- A legacy in Silicon Valley.
- Palo Alto's kind of this mythical place.
- Humans have always searched
for mythical, magical places.
Atlantis, El Dorado, Shangri-La,
but none of them have actually
been found besides one.
It started on a typical workday for me
when I was sifting through maps
which, yes, is something
I routinely just do.
Oh my God.
Paper maps, digitized maps, animated maps.
I just can't get enough.
So I'm sitting there
looking through some maps
and I stumble upon this.
This is a super old British
map of North America
with a giant island off the West Coast.
The island is labeled California.
Okay, so clearly some cartographer
just got this totally wrong
and made a mistake, right?
But wait, here's another
and another and another.
(mid tempo rhythmic music)
What is going on here?
This one's from 1785 or from 1750.
This one's from 1690 and from 1650.
Like, these maps of
California as an island
are spanning over 200 years.
Drawn by the Dutch and the Germans
and the British and the Japanese,
everyone is making a map
showing California as an island.
Is this like a tectonic plates thing?
Like, was California an island?
Because as we dug, we found
thousands of these maps.
California as an island everywhere.
I had to get to the bottom of this
to figure out what was going on here.
Luckily, I live in Washington DC
so there's somewhere I need to
go visit to figure this out.
(uptempo string music)
- [Train Announcer] This is
Metro Center transfer point.
- Hey, in case anyone is in DC
and is looking for a nuclear
fallout shelter, I found one.
The Library of Congress.
(suspenseful string music)
- [Library Worker] Hi there.
- [Johnny] That's also my
background as well, that map.
- Really?
- Yeah, yes.
I love it, it's just so beautiful.
Look at this puppy.
Wow.
Oh my God.
So wait, this is really weird.
I'm looking at these original maps, 1600s.
California is an island.
But then look at this one.
This is a map from like
a few decades earlier
and it shows California
accurately mapped earlier,
like, decades earlier in like the 1500s.
They had it right
and it looks pretty
accurate to the California
we know today.
And then, suddenly,
the whole world started mapping California
as an island.
What?
This is super weird.
(mid tempo techno music)
I vow now
to figure out what the hell
is going on with California.
(uplifting music)
This first started as a nerdy
history cartography question
but soon we fell into a way deeper story
than we signed up for.
The story of a mythical
place called California,
full of gold and magic and dreams,
fueled by people who weren't
totally grounded in reality
but rather in dreams of something bigger,
something different,
something that may or may not truly exist.
This island teaches us something bigger
than just how humans draw maps,
it's actually more about how
humans want to see the world,
about how fake ideas spread and why.
So let me show you how,
for hundreds of years,
California was an island
and how it still kind of is.
(upbeat music)
Hey, wake up for a second.
Do you mind if I chat
with you about something?
- I guess.
- I make YouTube videos
and, in order to do that,
I have a business that
allows me to do that
and the business is from sponsorships.
And so I'm making a video today
that's sponsored by a
company called Storyblocks,
which is a company I've used
for like a decade, even before
they came to sponsor a video.
Storyblocks is like a massive library
of visual and audio assets
that you can use to
make your videos better.
So creators of all size,
small, medium, large,
giant creative teams,
can subscribe to Storyblocks
at whatever budget or
price point they need
and can have an unlimited library
of like 4K amazing stock footage
that is diverse, that is ever-growing.
There's like thousands
and thousands of clips.
I use this all the time for my videos.
One of the big challenges for creators
is that it's really hard
to go out into the field
and shoot stuff
and so when you're making a video,
you don't have have a lot of
like really good visual assets.
With Storyblocks you
literally have a subscription
to an unlimited amount of
amazing visuals and sound effects
and animation templates.
It's a really freaking good deal.
In the video I'm making right now
it's about maps of California
and why California used to be an island.
You're gonna see like tons
of Storyblocks footage
that you won't even know
is Storyblocks footage
but it is, because I use it all the time.
So, anyway, thank you Storyblocks
for supporting this video.
Thank you for listening.
There's a link in my description.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel
but it also sends you to Storyblocks
so you can check out their pricing plan,
find something that fits your budget.
So now I'm headed back to the studio
to figure out what the hell
is going on with California
being mapped as an island.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, this is California
and this is Baja, California,
which is a part of Mexico.
And this is the Sea of Cortez.
It's not a full-blown sea,
it's actually a gulf,
the Gulf of California.
But we call it the Sea of Cortez
and you're about to find out why.
I actually went here once
when I was a 19 year-old Mormon missionary
living in Baja, California for two years.
Anyway, that is not important.
Let's talk about how
this became an island.
California originally was an idea, a myth.
It was a fictional setting
written into this novel
from 1510 in Spain,
like, 500 years ago.
California was like Atlantis
or the Garden of Eden.
The author described it
as an island populated by black women,
without any men existing there.
On the entire island
there was no metal other than gold
and it was ruled by Queen
Calafia, hence California.
Again, it was a fake place,
this is not a real place.
This is a guy writing a
novel about a fake place.
But while the author doesn't
say exactly where this is,
he basically says that it is, quote,
"at the right hand of the Indies."
Reminder that the Indies is like over here
in Southeast Asia.
This novel was published in Spain
about 50 years after the
invention of the printing press.
So printed books were like a
new technology, a big thing,
and this book was really popular.
Oh, and by the way,
the book also mentions that
the women in California
these like women warriors,
were, quote, "of beautiful
and robust bodies."
So you have new technology, books,
and beautifully robust women,
basically clickbait for
Spanish sailors in the 1500s.
They were out there exploring the world
and reading this book
while they were out to sea.
Oh, and remember, at this time,
these Spanish sailors are
out exploring the world
that Columbus had run into
when he was trying to find a
quicker way to get to Asia.
So it's like 10 years after Columbus
and Spain is sending people
to explore the new world
and by explore we mean wink
wink, extract resources
and like destroy the
population and make Spain rich.
And one of those expeditions
had this guy on board,
Hernán Cortés.
He came over as a young dude
but he quickly became one of
the most shrewd, aggressive,
like detail-oriented
colonizers that Spain had.
He goes on a big expedition
where he takes his 500 men and 16 horses
to go look for gold.
But Cortés was secretly
harboring another goal
for this expedition,
he was reading the romance novel
that everyone else was reading
and he kind of wanted to find California,
the fictional place in the book.
This would be like some
guy being out in like Nepal
on a hike or something
and he's like, I secretly
wanna find Middle Earth.
This kind of reminds me of
when I was in Wales in 2011
and I like secretly
wanted to find Hogwarts.
Like that kind of actually happened,
I was young.
And I was like, what if
I stumble upon Hogwarts?
Like, I get it Cortés, I get it.
You read it in the book
and you're like this
place is probably real.
Cortés, a legitimate Spanish Explorer,
is now looking for a fake place in a book.
So Cortés, after he stumbles
upon a great civilization,
allies with their
enemies and destroys them
with his guns and his smallpox,
small side note that can be
covered in a different time.
He eventually makes it over here.
Oh, by the way,
Cortés was kind of going
rogue this whole time,
he didn't have permission to do this.
And the Spanish leadership
were kind of freaking out.
So much so that Cortés had
to write a bunch of letters
justifying how good all
of this conquest was.
Anyway, Cortés sends out a mission
to go explore a little
further off this coast,
like around here.
Holy shit, they found something!
Cortés is so giddy
about this new discovery
that he writes a letter back to the king
saying that his men
talked to some natives.
(speaking in foreign language)
who, quote, "affirm
that there is an island
(speaking in foreign language)
inhabited only by women.
And there are no men,
that men come every once in a while
for them to like conceive
but they only keep the female children.
(speaking in foreign language)
It's only 10 days away
and that this island is
very rich in pearls, perlas,
and gold, y oro."
What?
Holy shit.
No men, only women, rich in gold.
(mid tempo music)
And where does Cortés
think he is right now?
Well, back when the world looked like this
in these people's minds,
Cortés is just to the right of the Indies,
which is exactly the location
described in the book
for California.
Cortés just discovered California.
Oh man, this is amazing.
I can feel the excitement of Cortés
who literally has spent years
thinking about this island
and now he thinks he's
found it, California.
But this is not what the
king of Spain signed up for.
So the king of Spain's like, no, dude, no,
we're not looking for
like mythical islands.
So he cuts off all of the funding
for any of these like expeditions.
So Cortés turns to his own personal wealth
and starts funding these
expeditions on his own,
to go map out and find
California, the island.
- Now I have to go to California.
- He personally goes on a voyage
and starts mapping and mapping,
and, lo and behold,
he's finding what looks like an island.
And they set up a colony
right here on this island
and they name the island California,
after the island of Queen
Calafia from the book.
(joyful music)
Okay, okay, okay.
Spoiler alert.
Remember that Cortés is like right here.
He's looking up this massive gulf
that he thinks is like a full-blown sea
that you can like circumnavigate,
but he's just like at the
bottom of Baja, California,
the peninsula.
And, worst of all, he's
burning his own cash
to keep exploring this
California island idea.
He's got California fever.
Maybe the first
but definitely not the last to have it.
- We're going to California.
- So Cortés keeps going and
he's feeling really excited.
He's like, if this is an island
then that means that this
sea probably extends up
and over the top of North America.
And maybe there's a whole strait
that goes all the way back to Spain,
making it super easy for us
to get between Spain and Asia.
And so he keeps mapping
and mapping and mapping and
oh no, womp womp,
Cortés ruined the myth for everyone,
and he like wasted away a bunch
of his money in the process.
But wait a minute,
this is like still the
beginning of the story.
Like, you see how much
longer is left in this video.
Like, this isn't the story.
What's crazy is what happens next.
Because even though Cortés found out
that California wasn't an island,
this was all before this happened.
And this is where the
story gets very juicy.
I am H-O.
Because somehow, even after all of this,
California still somehow managed
to make the world believe
that it was an island
for hundreds of years.
Okay, so after the whole
Cortés California dreaming incident,
Spain went on to ignore mapping California
for a very long time.
I mean, they were really busy conquering
and destroying and pillaging
a lot of other places in the region.
That is until the late 1500s,
where they catch wind of a British sailor
who happens to be their
literal sworn enemy,
who apparently just landed here
in what was gonna become Oregon
to claim all of this land for Britain.
And Spain was like, oh shit,
we gotta get back in the
game up there in that place,
what was it called again?
Cortés called it like California
after like from the novel or something.
Anyway, let's get some guys back up there
to like map it out.
We can't be asleep at the wheel
while the British are showing up
on the West Coast of North America.
So they send out this expedition of guys
to go map the West Coast of California.
Because, after all, if
you can map something
you can conquer it.
That's all they were thinking
about here was Britain.
Okay, and this is where things get so good
all because of another California dreamer.
This guy, Fray Antonio de la Ascensión,
a Spanish dude who wasn't
really a sailor or an explorer
or a cartographer,
he was kind of like a Catholic priest.
Aboard this expedition
there were legit map makers
and Fray Antonio was
literally the assistant.
He had some knowledge of map-making
but like he was literally the plan B
in case the main map maker died.
His job was really just to be religious.
Boy, did he do a lot more than that.
Fray Antonio, the peon assistant,
is actually the most important person
in this entire story,
because he had an agenda.
He really wanted Spain to
settle more aggressively
in California.
He felt the pull of California,
this mythical cool place on the West Coast
and it was his life's
mission to sell the idea
of Spain coming to California
and setting up more permanent settlements.
No one on board this expedition
was on the same page,
they were there just simply
mapping the West Coast,
that's all they were doing.
So they're going along this route,
Fray Antonio is on the
ship probably really bored,
'cause he's literally not doing anything.
He's looking overboard at this land
sort of in the distance,
and he starts to see
everything through his lens
of total bias.
This bias that California was amazing
and that Spain should settle it.
So they're passing like right here
on their way to the West Coast
and Fray Antonio writes,
quote, "Here begins the entrance
of the sea of California
which continues all the way
up north into this strait
that actually goes above North America.
And that, if you go, you can find passage
and navigation to Spain."
Wait, what?
Antonio, you're sitting on
the side of a boat right here
looking at basically this.
And from that you've deduced
that California is an island
and that there's a passage
above North America
that goes back to Spain?
I swear California does this to people.
It makes them ignore reality
in the name of a big dream.
- Yet the thought of
giving up everything here
and starting fresh in California,
it's so tempting and exhilarating.
- That is a theme here.
It happened to Cortés, it's
happening to Fray Antonio.
The guys on the ship are
like, "Dude, listen, Antonio
we get it,
you want Spain to settle in California
but that's not what this mission is about.
We're here to map the West
Coast of North America,
so just like chill out and do your job.
Sit around and be religious."
And Fray Antonio, like,
continues to wax super nostalgic.
He's like "San Diego is a very fine bay,
very fine anchorage,
protected from all the
winds and undertow."
Anyway, this expedition goes on
to fulfill its original purpose,
they mapped the West Coast of California
and they create this decent looking map.
But Fray Antonio walked
away from this mission
with a very different view.
He was convinced that
California was an island
and that there was a
mythical northern passage
that existed all the way back to Spain.
And he was so audacious to say, quote,
"I believe it will be
necessary and important to use"
what he's created, what he saw,
"for revising and correcting
the existing maps of the Earth"
since the existing maps
basically are very different
than what they are, in fact.
Translation, Spain, you
need to change your maps
to what I saw when I
was sitting there bored
looking over the boat,
because California is an island.
I mean, the confidence in
this guy is astounding.
Fray Antonio, like, makes
a big ruckus about this.
He tries to get Spain to change their maps
to make California an island.
It got to the point where the
official map maker of Spain
had to actually say, dude, you're wrong.
He said, quote, "Since no
proof of the lake of gold
or Strait of Anián",
which is that northern strait, "exists,
and since California has
not been circumnavigated,
little credit should be
given to these concepts."
Like dude, Fray Antonio, you're fake news,
you've been debunked, give it up.
But Fray Antonio does not give it up.
For the next two decades,
he continues to pitch his
fake version of California.
Sending loads of reports and maps
of his version of California,
what he saw,
all with the hope that
Spain would catch on
and come settle California.
And he started to actually
gain some followers.
He was pitching this, he
was like on a campaign
to like spread this idea
that California is an island,
I saw it with my own eyes.
And this is where it gets crazy
because guess who enters
the story, but pirates.
Early 1600s is like the
golden age for pirates.
Thousands of pirates were sailing the seas
and because Spain was like
the best at stealing stuff
and conquering places,
a Spanish ship was always
like jackpot for the pirates.
One such Spanish ship
was sailing back from
the new world to Spain
and onboard this ship was
one of Fray Antonio's letters
with a copy of his fake map
that showed California as an island.
And the ship was taken
over by Dutch pirates.
They took the ship, they
steal all the stuff,
and they stumble upon this
BS fake map from Fray Antonio
like a deepfake of the
map of North America.
And the pirates are
like, whoa, look at this.
The Spanish have California as an island.
Little context here,
maps back then were kind
of a national secret,
they didn't share maps very much.
So these Dutch guys are like holy shit,
we just discovered a big Spanish secret
that California is an island
and that there's actually a strait
that goes over the top of North America.
And they've been keeping
it from us the whole time.
So this map from Fray Antonio
gets back to the Netherlands
which, at the time,
were rising as like really
good map makers and sailors.
And boom.
A few years later, the fake
news just got retweeted.
Here it is,
this little map on the cover
page of some Dutch Atlas.
You see, for the first time,
California not connected to the mainland.
But wait, Cortés already mapped this
and showed that this wasn't
an island like 100 years ago.
No, what is happening?
The answer is Fray Antonio and pirates.
The myth was back.
Shortly after that, another map pops up.
The Dutch are slowly adopting the idea
of California as an island
and, in true fake news form,
everyone else was like, well
the Dutch they're legit,
they said that California is an island,
so I guess it is.
Word eventually spread to London,
where a famous map maker made this map.
Wait a minute, I know this map.
This is the one that
originally got me interested
in this whole entire topic.
Whoa, hold on.
And now I finally understand what it says
in this lower left.
"California, sometimes supposed to be
a part of the Western continent
but since by a Spanish
chart taken by Hollanders,
it is found to be a goodly island."
British cartographer, verified account,
retweets Fray Antonio's delusion
and suddenly this map with
California as an island
is legitimized and starts
to spread like wildfire.
"Seems legit" says a Dutch cartographer,
boom, retweet.
Then to Germany, then to
France, then to Italy,
then to Sweden
and Turkey is now drawing
California as an island
and Austria is drawing
California as an island.
And now Japan is drawing
Retweet, retweet, retweet.
Oof, man, where are the mods on this one?
Who's gonna fact check this?
The entire globe now thinks
that California is an island.
And so, yeah, this is how it happened.
Lots of wishful thinking,
a few crazy coincidences with pirates.
The whole world thinks
California's an island
for 200 years, 200 years,
that's like several lifetimes.
All because this one guy was
obsessed with a fake vision
and he wouldn't let it go.
Now, of course,
eventually explorers would
go and fact check this
and debunk it,
and maps, slowly but surely,
start to phase out
California as an island.
But I wanna argue that this
wasn't just Fray Antonio
and his wishful thinking,
I kind of think that
California does this to people.
Starting with Cortés and
continuing to this day,
California has continued to
have a mythical pull on people,
at least it has on European people
coming to California looking
for something magical,
looking for gold,
eventually actually finding gold.
Like, which is kind of insane to me
that the prophecy from a
1510 novel written in Spain
kind of came true in 1849,
when a bunch of people
found gold in California.
As the local people
who had been in California
for thousands of years
were exterminated and replaced
by industrious Europeans,
California remained and
continues to be a place
where people go to dream big.
- Palo Alto's kind of this mythical place
where, you know, all
the startups come from.
- [Johnny] Like Cortés,
who spent all of his money
trying to like figure out
what California was
or Fray Antonio, who spent
a good part of his life
trying to convince people
that California was an island,
something special
and, ultimately, it worked.
People go to California to chase dreams
that usually aren't grounded
in any sense of reality.
- You've been on the cover of magazines,
you could transform healthcare
not only here in America,
but around the world.
- They go and they push
and they push and they push
on some vision of something new,
even when those dreams rest
on spreading disinformation
to the whole world.
Was that too on the nose?
Am I stretching the analogy too much
with disinformation and propaganda
and Fray Antonio and Silicon Valley?
Like, are you getting this?
I'll stop.
The point is that, to me, this
is the beauty and the peril
of California as a place.
Yeah, it's attached to the continent,
we all know that
but California kind of is an island.
Ecologically, it has thousands
of totally unique species
of flora and fauna
that don't exist anywhere else.
Economically, it's the fifth
biggest economy on Earth.
And culturally, I mean,
California is its own culture.
And the result is that, today,
people still do what those guys were doing
in the 15/1600s,
coming west to California to chase dreams,
to chase gold, to chase something new.
In that sense, California is an island,
Fray Antonio was right the whole time.
Okay, see ya.
(uplifting techno music)